[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition of a matrix
X into the product of three matrices u
times Sigma times V transpose and very
often we're going to do a truncated SVD
where we only keep a rank or
approximation where R is much smaller
than the original dimensions of our data
matrix X but this begs a question in
real-world examples how do I choose the
rank of this truncation R it's not
always obvious how to choose the number
of modes are in your data X ok and
there's a really nice paper by gavage
and Donahoe from 2014 where they show
that under certain conditions on the
structure of X that there is an optimal
criterion for choosing this rank R and
in particular they assume that your
matrix X is actually a product a low
rank matrix so that it's actually the
product of two rank R a column our
columns times our rows so it's really a
rank R matrix plus noise kind of a light
noise matrix of Gaussian distributed
noise and if your X really is low rank
plus noise then they give an optimal
criterion for how to choose this rank R
and in particular you take all of the
singular values Sigma J that are bigger
than some threshold value and you keep
those and any that are lower than then
the threshold you throw away or you zero
them out and so that's how you choose
the r modes to keep based on the are
singular values that are above the noise
floor ok and again I'm gonna sound like
a broken record here but if you want to
use a new mathematical method try it out
on a system where you know the answer
that's what we do in research all the
time so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna cook up an example that's an
exactly Rank 2 system so we're gonna
cook up an example that is exactly a
Rank 2 matrix I'm gonna have two columns
x two rows I'm gonna add Gaussian white
noise to it and we're gonna see how this
gavage
how hard threshold thing works okay so
again we're going to we're going to
essentially create a matrix you Sigma
and V that are low rank two columns two
rows and two elements of Sigma and I'm
building them like this so my two
columns of U is going to be a cosine
times a Gaussian e to the minus T
squared is a Gaussian so it's kind of
this Gaussian decaying envelope with a
cosine wave in there and a sine wave
with eleven frequency and similarly my V
columns are going to be a sine wave
times a Gaussian and a cosine wave and
if I multiply these up x equals u times
Sigma times V transpose then this is the
matrix I get here so this is my low rank
matrix it's exactly rank two I built it
so that it has rank two and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna corrupt it
with white noise and we're gonna see how
the gavage Donoho criteria and filters
and selects a rank two sub matrix from
the SVD okay so it's really simple to
add noise I'm adding unit variance
Gaussian white noise so I just take X
plus Sigma times n P random dot R and n
the same size as X and now this is my
noisy data this is the data in X I'm
pretending that this is the only data
I've ever seen even though I know that
it was generated from a rank 2 system
above okay and we're gonna compute the
SVD of this matrix and we're gonna try
to figure out what rank to truncate so
when I compute the SVD of this we're
gonna compute the SVD here and we're
going to run this gavage Donoho
criterion here so here the cutoff this
this threshold is 4 over the square root
of three times the square root of n
where n is the size of this square
matrix times Sigma which is the known
noise magnitude now if you have a
rectangular matrix or you have an
unknown noise magnitude you have to use
a slightly more complicated formulation
also in their paper that works really
well for rectangular matrices where you
don't know the magnitude of noise but
here our life is a little bit easier and
again we're gonna pick R to be the
number of singular values that are above
this threshold cut off and then we're
going to reconstruct X only from those
two modes that are kept and this is what
we get so this is the kind of cleaned
matrix after you use this optimal
Gammage dot I have a threshold to
discover the rank of the system and you
can see there's a little bit of artifact
in this but this is very very clean
compared to that noisy matrix now if you
do something that you've liked pick the
rank R so that it captures 90% of the
variance of the matrix X and this is
actually quite common people often pick
the the P OD or PCA the number of modes
to be so that you capture 90 percent or
95 or 99 percent of the the energy or
the variance of X if you do that kind of
naive criterion where you pick all of
the singular values that are larger that
capture more than 90% of the they
capture up to 90% of the energy you get
a really really bad truncation you have
way too many modes you're keeping and
you're keeping a lot of noise modes so
the gavage Donoho criterion does a great
job identifying that this is actually a
rank 2 system where as kind of the the
classical wisdom of energy based
truncation is really really crummy here
and you can see this when you actually
plot the singular values so here we're
going to do a log plot semi log plot of
the diagonal elements of this Sigma
matrix these singular values and we're
going to interpret kind of what's what's
happening here
so in white we see the singular value
distribution this blue line is the
optimal gavage Donoho hard threshold
cutoff and so we're only keeping these
two singular values that are above the
noise floor and we're throwing away
everything that's below the noise floor
ok so most of the remainder of this this
white line looks like what you would get
if you just SVD this noise matrix if you
SPD this
then the Sigma values would look a lot
like what we see over here okay and
anything that's peeking up over this
over this noise floor those are the rank
modes that we're gonna keep okay and if
you zoom in you can see that there are
in fact two modes that are well above
the noise floor everything else is
pushed below so we can actually identify
that quite cleanly and this is the
cumulative energy of the first our modes
what I'm plotting here in yellow are all
of the bad modes you would include if
you try to keep 90% of the variance of
your noisy data matrix you'd end up
having 400 modes when you really only
need two modes these you can actually
see the little blue modes down here
those are the ones you actually want to
keep okay so really really powerful
method this is the hard threshold in the
optimal hard thresholding method of
gavage and Donoho to choose the rank r
of your matrix very powerful and you can
also apply this to systems that are not
like toy systems where you cooked up a
low rank matrix plus noise you can apply
this to the eigenfaces data we worked in
the last example so I encourage you to
do that actually take the eigenfaces
example run it through the gavage Donoho
hard threshold in algorithm and look and
see how it actually segments the matrix
into structure and then stuff which is
kind of fluctuations or noise okay thank
you